[Musik]
es war nachts haben anbetung
ich habe panik bekommen okay was jetzt
kann gar nicht in mein zimmer kommen
abends
naja sie reingekommen die tür zugemacht
hat angefangen mich auszuziehen und ich
habe also immer noch nicht fassen grad
ok macht das jetzt wirklich und ich weiß
ob er macht das jetzt und dann war ich
auch schon wie versteinert und
weggetreten in dem augenblick eigentlich
wo ist gewusst was da jetzt machen dass
ich nichts machen kann die im augenblick
bin ich wie ausgelöscht worden
das war der schlimmste ich bin doris
reißinger und ich bin als junger uns
frau und luster missbraucht worden
sodann gema wir gehen einfach hier an
dem markt formal dafür kämpfe ich
wirklich dass die menschen endlich zu
ihrem recht finden nämlich gehört zu
werden dass ihre verletzungen ernst
genommen werden also da bin ich wirklich
da kenne ich keine keine kein pardon
kein pardon ich bin mutter lena
pastoralreferentin und haben großes
interesse daran dass endlich eine
aufarbeitung passiert
wir fordern den missbrauchsskandal in
der katholischen kirche umfassend
aufzuklären
dringlich ist
[Musik]
ich glaube wirklich dass gott so meine
erste bezugsperson war das kind braucht
man jemanden dem man vollkommen
vertrauen kann und ich habe ziemlich
früh gemerkt man eltern können das nicht
sein für mich weil die haben genug
eigene probleme
dieses gefühl aha jetzt genau ins
kloster das war auch dieses gefühl genau
dafür nicht auch gott liebt mich so sehr
dass er mich ruft in seinen nachfolger
braut christi sein
ich war früher im klub nicht genau
nein ich finde du bist so gezielt so
angekommen als hätte so ein schönes
leben gehabt und nicht irgendwie farming
behalten ich versteh ich war das älteste
mädchen war ziemlich früh in der rolle
die dann irgendwie im kloster
weitergegangen ist
mithelfen die eigenen bedürfnisse
wünsche vorstellungen nach stellt sich
selbst vergessen
das habe abschneiden war in der
waschküche mitschwestern mit einer
schere hat was mit dem haare abschneiden
was so moment wo ich ja okay ich halte
das jetzt aus und ich hab dann trotzdem
gewollt so aber ich habe mich dafür
geschämt dass ich geholt hat weil meine
haare sind gar nicht wichtig ja das hat
sich alles so traurig an war es auch
aber deswegen ist auch für mich jetzt
hier zu sitzen
bei dir und regelmäßig hier zu sein und
möchte schön machen zu lassen eigentlich
das ist so was besonderes ich habe mir
noch ein paar fotos
das sieht man wie ich damals ausgesehen
habe diese wadenlangen rückkehr diese
schrecklichen aber auch vor allem mein
gesicht und meine körperhaltung wie ich
nie hat es ein gebrochener mensch der
hier zu sehen ist
das bin ich mir ich war auf dem bild das
ist schwester doris das was aus mir
gemacht worden ist ich will dass diese
menschen alle aufwachen und realisieren
welche verantwortung sie ganz persönlich
dafür haben dass es keine weiteren opfer
gibt und dass den opfern die da sind
gerechtigkeit zuteil wird und warum
mussten die haare ab weil in der
gemeinschaft in der ich waren auch
männer priester patrice und es war
irgendwie immer die angst im raum dass
die irgendwie in versuchung geraten wenn
sie merken dass ihre mitschwestern
frauen
die gemeinschaft in die doris reisinger
mit 19 jahren eintritt heißt das werk
erst nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
gegründet richtet sie sich streng nach
der reinen katholischen glaubenslehre
die amtskirche unterstützt solche
neugründungen vasta harmonie verpackt
wird ist im grunde eine autoritäre logik
die besagt es gibt eine wahrheit und es
gibt ein lehramt und das vermittelt er
diese wahrheit und dieser logik führt
direkt in der missbrauch die es in sich
missbräuchlich schönhorst sucht man
danke jutta lehnert arbeitet als
pastoralreferentin in koblenz und ist
bei der katholischen kirche angestellt
sie vertritt eine ganz andere theologie
als das lehramt unter dem doris
reisinger so zu leiten hatte
feministisch liberaldemokratische sie
hat theologie studiert und hält die
amtskirche für unchristlich also das
evangelium wird verletzt durch die
kirche das ist das problem ist das ist
ein
das ist ein zutiefst der widerspruch den
kann ich nicht ertragen
in dieser missbrauchsgeschichte das muss
jedem klar sein steht die gesamte
struktur der kirche auf dem spiel
das stellt fragen an die beteiligung der
frauen
es stellt fragen an die als theologie
ist stellt fragen an die gesamte
konstruktion der kirche als machtapparat
und weil sie das wissen genau weil sie
das wissen wird das immer noch ab
immer wieder melden sich bei jutta
lehnert menschen die sagen sie seien in
der kirche missbraucht worden
sie wollen dass ihnen jemand zuhört das
bistum trier für das jutta lehnert
arbeitet hört nicht zu so empfindet sie
es
ich glaube sie haben die langen
wirkungen einer solchen gewalt hat an
einem menschen durch das ganze leben
hindurch das ist noch nicht emotional
erfasst also hier fehlt es an empathie
man müsse dem jesus verstanden haben ja
und der jesus müsste sie berühren
wirklich berühren ich glaube da fehlt es
das evangelium ist für jutta lehnert ein
ganz persönlicher auftrag deswegen
kümmert sie sich ehrenamtlich um
missbrauchsopfer dieser junge mann hatte
ihr am telefon erzählt er sei von einem
priester im bistum trier missbraucht
worden
heute lebt er im bayerischen bad tölz in
einer einrichtung für alkoholkranke
mutter lehnert besucht ihn auf eigene
kosten ermutigt wieder andere sie haben
ein gutes wort eben dafür gefunden dass
das schweigen
ich glaube dass der fall hat der wagen
ja so freut ist sympathisch also da kam
kumpelhaft rüber im garten da gab es um
diese alkohol partys also reichlich
alkohol konsumiert wurde
und dann gab's halt die übergriffe die
hat ja massiv waren konnten sie sich
wehren wie viel das in der situation
alleine mit ihm zu sein ja und da
irgendwas zu sagen da hat ja da waren
wir wie gelähmt
was dich neben ich jetzt was sagt wie
reagiert also mein eindruck ist dass sie
auch als sagen wir mal aus unsicheren
sozialen verhältnissen heraus vielleicht
auch ein bisschen geschwächt war
ich habe es versucht zu verdrängen also
hab' mal gesagt kommt das sagst du jetzt
keinem auch weil es einfacher ist es
glaubt hier keiner
als er sich traut den priester
anzuzeigen räumt dieser den übergriff
teilweise ein
der missbrauch ist aber verjährt die
polizei informiert das bistum trier aber
niemand meldet sich bei dem jungen mann
erst zehn jahre später nimmt das bistum
kontakt zu ihm auf damals ist kardinal
marx bischof von trier
er hat inzwischen eingeräumt nicht
genügend nachgefragt zu haben
erwarten sie vom bischof und von der
bistumsleitung den dingen stärker
nachzugehen
dass man vielleicht eher menschen
ermutigt auch zu sprechen denn es ist ja
nicht einfach zu sprechen die leute die
vor ort leben in der gemeinde die halten
zu ihrem fahrrad die glauben das nicht
sie wollen das nicht wahrhaben
dass es so ist fahrer ist halt noch mal
was besonderes diener gottes und an tina
gutes tut halt keine maus das ist doch
so ist habe ich erfahren müssen ich habe
so das gefühl dass viele ganz normale
gläubige sehr empört sind über den
missbrauch der passiert solange der weit
weg ist das ist sehr schmerzhaft sich
darauf gefasst zu machen dass auch die
menschen in der kirche von denen nicht
begeistert bin dass sie auch das
einkommen diesen schritt diesen schmerz
aushalten zu können
die muss jeder gehen egal ob bischof ist
oder priester oder aufgrund weiterer
anzeigen wird der priester 2013 in den
vorläufigen ruhestand versetzt
inzwischen läuft auch ein
kirchenrechtliches verfahren gegen ihn
bischof in trier ist heute stephan
ackermann
er ist auch missbrauchsbeauftragte der
deutschen bischofskonferenz ein
interview hat er abgelehnt
ich würde ihn wahrscheinlich als erstes
fragen warum er keinen offenen ehrlichen
umgang mit den opfern pflegt warum er so
kalt ihnen gegenüber ist aber man kann
ja keine menschen empathie an diktieren
sie müsste da sein und sie müsste
sichtbar sein opfer bräuchten eigentlich
das gefühl dass in dem moment wo sie
sich lockerten die ganze kirche
geschlossen bei ihnen ist und ziehen
ihre mitte nimmt das immer noch so dass
man als opfer
wenn wie außenseiter wird und angreifer
und lesben schmutzer und jemand wo man
nicht weiß ob man dem glauben kann und
jemand der anstrengend ist und dass das
muss aufhören
auch doris reisinger hat theologie
studiert 2011 ist sie aus ihrer
geistlichen gemeinschaft ausgetreten
heute arbeitet sie als personalberaterin
in darmstadt
es gibt niemand der mir sagt wie ich
mich hier fühlen soll und was das eben
dass eine berufung ist und was gott
jetzt von dem was ich mache sondern
wichtig seien hier mache ich meinen job
ich mache da kommst du unterschiedlich
sie freuen und als ordensfrau fühlt sie
sich kontrolliert und manipuliert
je mehr sie sich selbst vergessen umso
näher käme sie gott das glaubt doris
reisinger damals selbst und dann durften
wir ja auch nicht über persönliches
miteinander reden
ich sollte ja das was ich denke und was
ich will und was ich fühle aufgeben oder
hinten anstellen und mich öffnen für das
was hier gesagt worden ist und das hat
das hat funktioniert
ich habe überhaupt nichts gefühlt ich
habe überhaupt nichts gedacht ich
überhaupt nichts gewollt auch zum teil
wenn es wirklich schlecht gegangen ist
habe ich halt geglaubt jetzt in diesem
moment wo ich irgendwie leide ist gott
bei mir
das war wie das wie das kleine mädchen
das das gefühl hatte meine eltern sind
überfordert irgendwie aber gott ist
immer da im theologiestudium kommt sie
zu dem schluss dass sich niemand an
maßen darf zu wissen was gut ist und was
gott will
heute ist sie sich sicher jeder hat ein
recht auf seine eigene spiritualität
wenn wir uns radikal konsequent für eine
logik der gott unmittelbarkeit und des
eigenen gewissens entscheiden würden
dann würde einfach die institution und
die struktur auch ganz anders aussehen
nämlich so dass jeder mit dem was ihr
in seinem gewissen erfährt und spürt
eine stimme hat in dieser kirche
jetzt will sie verhindern dass sich
andere von der kirche missbrauchen
lassen
wir wissen verfügen mittlerweile über
sexuellen missbrauch aber da findet ihr
auch andere missbrauch stadt
spiritueller missbrauch ausbeutung von
arbeitskraft
sie erzählen dass jetzt ein bisschen so
als würden sie über eine sekte sprechen
ist das zu hart nein das ist gar nicht
zu hart also die gemeinschaft in der ich
war ganz sicher eine sekte um darüber zu
informieren schreibt sie unter ihrem
mädchennamen doris wagner bücher geht in
talkshows und gibt interviews siebe
möglichst viel öffentlichen druck auf
die kirche aufbauen
deshalb hat sie sich auch für eine kino
dokumentation filmen lassen
ein programmkino in mainz dass ihr so
viele menschen zuhören wollen hat für
doris reisinger etwas befreiendes
in dem moment in dem ich mich im plus
waren sich vergewaltigt worden
richtig so allein
ich war dass du allein und jetzt stehe
ich hier von psalm mit 100 leuten und
ich bin eben nicht mehr erleiden
das ist das überwältigende gefühl
cosmos gelegt wo das normal war als frau
bist du dafür verantwortlich dass
niemand dein körper sieht oder ahnt dass
so eine frau ist
der welt gelebt habe ich als frau eine
frau
diese autoritäre logik hat auch mein
frauenbild geprägt dass er frauen
einfach dadurch glücklich werden dass
sie ihre weibliche berufung leben die
darin besteht im hintergrund zu bleiben
kochen putzen zu denen sich nicht
wichtig zu machen und es ist einfach für
andere menschen schön zu machen schon
irgendwelche fragen aus dem publikum was
glauben sie wie sich die zukunft der
kirche irgendwie entwickeln wird es gibt
keine rechtsstaatlichkeit in der kirche
und es gibt keine demokratischen
strukturen und sie können machen was sie
wollen selbst bin das ganze kirchen
folge anders denkt bringen wir da oben
nicht durch und deswegen gibt es auch
keine lösung also die einzige lösung wie
die kriege sich ändern könnte wäre dass
der papst selber sein altes amt
abschafft wie mir das passiert das habe
ich gesagt ich bin die einzige und dann
bin ich ausgetreten und ich habe
angefangen zu recherchieren und bin
drauf gestoßen unter anderem auf eine
studie von therapeuten die ordensfrauen
betreut haben die vergewaltigt worden
waren
im fällen aus der ganzen welt von
brasilien bisschen die philippinen und
in rom ist nichts passiert doris
reisinger wendet sich nach ihrem
austritt aus der gemeinschaft mehrfach
an papst franziskus sie will dass das
oberhaupt der katholischen kirche zu
ihrem und zum weltweiten missbrauch
stellung bezieht
nach über vier jahren erhält sie eine
antwort
wir danken ihnen für ihre sorge um das
wohl der kirche und bitte beten sie doch
vor den heiligen vater und er bietet
auch für sie
und da ich weiß gar nicht mehr wofür ich
bitten 2 da fällt einem nichts mehr
zahlen
auch dieser papst ist für sie teil eines
erstarrten systems
sie will eine grundsätzliche diskussion
keine kosmetischen veränderungen früher
war ich die die nichts gewusst hat die
kontrolliert worden ist hätte gerne mit
jemandem offen zu sprechen und jetzt hat
sich das umgedreht und ich hatte überall
meine geschichte alle leute hören mir zu
und es entsteht ein druck auf die kirche
jetzt wissen leute etwas über die kirche
das ist gewusst die wissen das war ich
das erzählt habe
vielleicht entsteht auch ein politischer
druck von außen von der bundesregierung
die irgendwann mal auf den trichter
kommen zu sagen wir können uns in
unseren politischen system kann in so
mächtigen akteur leisten der
menschenrechte nicht achtet
ich kann dann für die kirche nicht mehr
garantieren wenn hier keine aufarbeitung
stattfinde
aber es muss aus der selbsterkenntnis
kommen also zu erkennen wie weit man
sich schon von diesem jesus von nazareth
entfernt hat und darüber erschrecken
das sind wir jetzt und das wollen wir
und dürfen wir doch nicht sein
es ist nikolaustag jutta lena schlüpft
in die rolle des heiligen bischofs
doch sie glaubt nicht dass sich in der
katholischen kirche etwas verändern
würde wenn einfach nur mehr frauen das
sagen hätten im moment wo das system so
starr und versteinert ist würde man als
frau das nur unterstützen
man würde wahrscheinlich dieselben
fehler machen in dieselben
handlungsmuster fall
es muss zuerst grundsätzlich das system
sich ändern
die man ihr als frau eine leitende
funktion übernimmt
jede frau muss jetzt wissen dass man in
diesem system immer er verbrecher zu
gemeinde leitern macht als frauen
das ist böse aber es ist so tallinn hat
setzt auf revolution von unten
sie will den nachwuchs sensibilisieren
hier sind es studenten der katholischen
hochschulgemeinde koblenz vor denen sie
den missbrauch anspricht ich habe
darüber nachgedacht was das mögen mit
uns macht belogen haben die bischöfe im
missbrauchsskandal
wie es aussieht sogar international der
erste schritt sich selbst belügen sich
den blick auf sich selbst in ordnung
biegen
ein priester muss sein selbstbild retten
und auch ein bischof darauf könnte
städten bin ja selber einer
und weiß ganz gut was ein hirsch in
bedrohlichen lage so tut und so reichert
sich das lügen an von kirchenmann zu
kirchenmann vertuscht verschickt die
täter weiter lügen das ist wie ein gift
das uns alle in der mitte trifft kriegt
nichts kann man einem einen egomanen
bischof mehr irritieren als wenn man
über ihm lacht im lächerlich macht das
das ist prima ich habe immer gesagt ich
wünsche jedem bild eine geschiedene
schwester
[Musik]
hier legt doris reisinger ihr gelübde ab
wird braut christi wie sie es sich schon
als kind gewünscht hatte als es soweit
ist hat sie jahre der geistlichen
manipulation hinter sich so sieht sie es
heute in der küche habe ich meine
geliebte abgedeckt 2007 einer der
einsamsten tage meines lebens eigentlich
war zu dem zeitpunkt vier jahre in der
gemeinschaft und ich war schon so
innerlich ausgewählt und so einsam
ich habe nur gedacht es ist meine
berufung und gott weiß wofür das gut ist
und ich vertraue rottweil wenn ich
damals von das gefühl gehabt hätte das
ist überhaupt nicht gut
dann hätte ich das nicht überlebt also
dann wäre ich zusammengebrochen und
diesen tag nur kurz nach ihrem gelöbnis
sei sie vergewaltigt worden
der priester bestreitet das bis heute
der sex sei einvernehmlich gewesen
doris eisinger zeigt ihn nach ihrem
austritt an
doch die ermittlungs verfahren werden
eingestellt sie habe sich nicht genügend
gewährt genau das war ihr in diesem
system unmöglich
wer glaubt durch leiden käme er gott
näher hält still
er trägt das martyrium das zeigt uns
doris reisinger in einer kirche die sie
damals häufig besucht
[Musik]
die herrliche es wird ein katholischer
frauen als vorbild vorgestellt frauen
werden meistens dadurch heilig dass sie
leiden und dass die jungen frauen sind
und bleiben das sie dienen dass sie sich
unterordnen oder sie sterben könnten
zugespitzt gesagt
bei jungfräulichkeit geht es ja nicht
nur um sexualität sondern es geht so um
eine geisteshaltung der enthaltsamkeit
es sich versagens dieses vorbild der
absoluten enthaltsamkeit selbstlosigkeit
bedürfnis losigkeit und der bereitschaft
auch zu sterben wenn gott es will
das ist so dass es steckt so tief im
katholizismus drin wenn man das
betrachtet als ein als ein programm den
man sich leute gefüge gemacht und
menschen dazu bringt dass sie nicht
aufmucken dann ist das perfekt
für mich hat das einfach sehr langes hin
gemacht so viel auszuhalten weil ich
viel zu spät angefangen habe mich denken
zutrauen dass ich auch möchte ich bin
das ist auch wichtig ist so gut geht
mit dieser leidensbereitschaft hält sie
auch den missbrauch irgendwie aus zwei
jahre lang wagt sie nicht zu sprechen
er starrt sie weiß nicht wohin sie sich
wenden soll kann mit niemandem darüber
reden
ich habe erst mal geschwiegen ich habe
geschwiegen in dem gefühl ich werde für
immer schweigen
das nehme ich mit ins grab und dann kam
2010 und in den zeitungen über all diese
schlagzeilen
und da hatte ich verstanden das ist
genau das was mir passiert ist und ich
aber auch verstanden
da muss man drüber sprechen das muss
sich ändern aber das passiert nur wenn
die opfer sprechen zuerst erzählt sie
eine mit bruder dem sie vertraut davon
er unterstützt sie sie treffen sich
einfach um zu reden
heute ist sie mit ihm verheiratet wir
haben uns hier in dem park getroffen
heimlich natürlich über die
missbrauchten ich erlebt hatte mit
jemandem zu sprechen wir schlimmes
vergehen gewesen
das waren zwei dinge die wahnsinnig
aufregend waren daran hier diesen mann
zu treffen das war erstens das verbot
und als gruppe die die angst das nicht
zu dürfen und es war es war aber auch
das gefühl da ist jemand der mich liebt
das hat sie gerettet
mit seiner hilfe fasst sie den mut auch
mit ihrer oberen zu sprechen
voller angst man werde ihr die schuld an
dem missbrauch geben hab dann meiner
verantwortlichen gesagt es muss dir was
sagen die war völlig fassungs so ist er
ist wirklich buchstäblich rotz und
wasser über das gesicht gelaufen und die
ba knallrot und hab mich angeschrieben
das muss man im ganzen haus gehört haben
und hat sich dann er hat dann zuerst
wissen wollen habt ihr verhütet und wie
sie diese frage gestellt war mir ganz
gut
die will gar nicht verstehen was ich
erzählt habe und dann hat sie mir aber
vergeben und ich gewusst dass es
hoffnungslos
da habe ich dann das erste mal
selbstmordgedanken gehabt
ein knappes jahr später habe dann auch
noch ihr beichtvater in der beichte
versucht sie zu küssen
für katholiken ein schweres vergehen
gegen das sakrament dieser priester
arbeitet damals auch in der
glaubenskongregation und wird 2009 zum
chef der abteilung befördert haben
der pater hat schwierigkeiten mit
frauchen müssen verständnis haben und
nach dem austritt habe ich das extra
nochmal an den präfekten der
glaubenskongregation geschrieben das war
damals gerade in der müller und aber
auch eine antwort bekommen und in dem
schreiben heißt es dass er das zugegeben
hat und dass es sich für seinen
unruhiges verhalten entschuldigt
denen ist das egal ob derart missbraucht
hat wir haben keine lust aufzuräumen
die glaubenskongregation ist dass die
gast eri um das mit kindesmissbrauch
beauftragt ist hier werden diese ferne
die schweren fälle werden hier behandelt
und es kann nicht sein dass genau in
dieser installation ein täter arbeitet
und jetzt sitzt du da hinter irgendeinem
dieser fenster
ich glaube ganz ehrlich dass ich in dem
ich jetzt hier stehe dazu beitragen kann
dass das aufhört und das fühlt sich gut
an
[Musik]
jutta lennart macht sich von koblenz auf
den weg nach trier
dort trifft sie mitglieder von missmut
missbrauchsopfer im bistum trier
gemeinsam wollen sie forderungen
ausarbeiten
dass das fernsehen dabei ist hilft ihnen
auch sie suchen die öffentlichkeit als
verbündeten
[Musik]
das ist auch ein grund warum viele
jugendliche in der kirche weg gehen die
kann die verlogenheit einfach nicht
ertragen
das ist so in der kirche hat man nur
eine chance wenn man gleichzeitig die
öffentlichkeit informiert zur forderung
gehört auch vielmehr kirchliche
unabhängigkeit in die bearbeitung der
sache zu bringen also
das zum beispiel betroffene zeugen von
einer
öffentlichen stelle und nicht
kirchenintern angehört werden
betroffenen fällt es oft schwer sich
öffentlich zu äußern
eine auseinandersetzung mit der
organisation der täter ist für viele
schmerzhaft jutta lehnert möchte ihnen
helfen forderungen zu stellen über ihr
persönliches leid hinauszuwachsen
doch oft wollen sie genau darüber mit
ihr sprechen mein vater sagte zu mir
weitergeht in onkel wecken und ich gehe
die treppe hoch mit 4
der onkel lässt mich in sein bett legen
und fummelt an mir rum
aber der war der onkel war erregt ich
wusste nicht was das ist
er hat mir sein geschlechtsteil gezeigt
ich wusste auch nicht was das ist
ich habe massive angstzuständen und in
den massiven angstzuständen kamen wir
die erinnerungen und assoziationen also
man glaubt aber dass so der der
missbrauch für die stärke der hat mein
ganzes leben zerstört aber ein priester
des bistums jana und das weiß auch der
bischof ackermann
aber wie gesagt die innere schuldet die
trage ich noch heute
wir wissen dass mittlerweile das ist
teil der täter strategie ist dem in dem
opfer einem gefühl der mitschuld zu
erwecken und täter wissen was kinder
brauchen sie suchen sich auch diejenigen
heraus sie dann die zuwendung besonders
nötig haben oder
ganz besonders großer freund und mehr
als ein großer freund das war so was
wieder wie das war wie eine jugendliebe
wenn die kinder eine kinderliebe auch
keinen onkel oder tante gehabt der
meinen schoß gesessen haben das kann man
ja machen ist doch klar das ist jetzt
wieder was persönliches das dass man
also sexuelle berührungen als
fortsetzung der beispiel betrachtet als
kind ja wenn ich da nichts zu bieten
habe und ich sage da das habe ich nicht
gemacht
ich bin schon mal berührt und und der
priester dann auch ein beispiel das so
hinterfragt und dann leder das kind dann
ins auto ein und fährt mit ihnen durch
die landschaft und fängt an ihn so zu
streicheln und zu fühlen und dann
passiert dann dass das kind meint der
testet das jetzt ich glaube dass wir
keine priester mehr in dem sinne
brauchen also dieses sakramental
überhöhte das brauchen wir menschen ist
das gehört für mich überhaupt nicht zum
christentum dass es eigentlich halten
ist das freund von mir sagt immer gott
braucht keine vorzimmerdame
eine weihe ist nichts anderes als ein
auftrag ja ein auftrag von einer
gemeinde arbeiten mein verdacht ist dass
hier so gedacht wird sobald man die wahl
hat tritt man in eine andere existenz
weise ein und ist dann jeder kritik
enthoben
ich setze meine eigene theologie da
gehen und habe das als missbrauch gottes
sandler auf das ist missbrauch gottes
die behauptung priester seien wegen
ihrer weihe näher an gott und im besitz
der wahrheit führt auch für doris
reisinger zwangsläufig in den missbrauch
von macht von spiritualität von menschen
sie fordert eine verteilung der macht
auf viele schultern gewaltenteilung dass
sich theologisch super begründen
eigentlich lässt sich theologisch ein
system in dem einige wenige mächtige
über alle anderen bestimmen schwer
rechtfertigen
das bistum essen hat doris reisinger
eingeladen über die gefahren religiöser
macht zu sprechen
mit dieser macht könnten priester die
gläubigen ganz einfach manipulieren
unter theologen wird das als
spiritueller missbrauch diskutiert für
doris reisinger eine vorstufe zu
körperlichen übergriffen wie ich das
erste mal geistlicher missbrauch gehört
habe und auch die these von plasma dass
das geistliche missbrauch sexuelle
missbrauch immer voraus geht
da habe ich angefangen zu verstehen was
hier passiert ist
das spirituelle manipulation kann sehr
subtil sein aber auch sehr sehr brutal
und sie fängt eben damit an dass
derjenige depp leitet oder der führt
sich selbst überhöht was diese autorität
sein was dieser führer sagt das ist die
wahrheit ein wichtiges werkzeug und ein
spiel zur manipulation ist wertung sie
haben einen text den sie großartig
finden und sie geben den genannten zu
lesen und es sagt ja konnte ich jetzt
nichts damit anfangen uns zu sagen ja
schade
das ist das ist auch schon eine wertung
nach ich habe ihn auch dazu ein video
mitgebracht
ich finde das exemplarisch dafür wie
menschen in der katholischen kirche
geistliche manipuliert werden ich habe
vor wenigen tagen den spruch gesehen und
das buch heißt gottlos glücklich
was wirst du antworten wenn jemand sagen
würde du ich bin total glücklich ohne
gott
da haben es dem hamsterrad kann auch
glücklich sein
also mal ehrlich ich bin denn ich glaube
nicht dass alle besen menschen
unglücklich sind
der punkt ist das christentum lehrt
überhaupt nicht in erster linie glück
sonst christentum lehrt wahrheit der
punkt es nicht findest du dich raus ob
das mit jesus passt und glaub mal ein
bisschen ag zugleich bessern der punkt
warum du jesus folgen sollte ist dass
sie wahr halte was haben sie gesehen was
haben sie gemerkt was macht dieser mann
und zu manipulieren und wie genau
manipulierte das was zählt ist wahrheit
und was er nicht explizit gesagt hat
aber was durch seine ganze art wie er
auftritt deutlich geworden ist derjenige
der die wahrheit kennt und er sich sagt
das ist er
und er sagt im prinzip du darfst dich
nicht darauf berufen bis der geht und ob
du glücklich bist oder nicht
das spielt keine rolle sondern du musst
du musst dich der wahrheit unterordnen
und das ist das worauf es ankommt im
christentum und das ist fatal weil wenn
wenn man das macht und ein mensch einem
das ab kauft kann man alles mit ihm
machen als schwester ist mir nach dem
eintrag gesagt worden dass es wichtig
ist dass wir immer lächeln um zeuthen
ist für unser berufung zu geben und ich
habe die ganze zeit nur noch gelächelt
ich bin nur noch gewissen lächeln durch
die gegend gelaufen damit alle sehen wie
glücklich ich bin
das hat aber nicht verhindert dass ich
sobald ich eine mutter alleine war mir
die tränen übers gesicht gelaufen und
ich merke es ist und das ist das eher
spirituelle gewalt an der basis sind
viele von den missständen erschüttert
und bereit für grundsätzliche
veränderungen jedenfalls in deutschland
doch diese menschen haben in der
katholischen kirche keine macht so ein
bisschen zwischen hoffnung dass die
kirche sich da bestenfalls ganzheitlich
verbessert und auf der anderen seite je
nach tagesform auch in richtung
verzweiflung sich an diesem riesigen
apparat und dieser ihrer hier auch die
zähne auszubeißen
ich glaube nicht dass die menschen die
mir das angetan haben jemals verstehen
werden was sie mir angetan haben
aber ich bin von denen nicht mehr
abhängig
ich hab hoffnung geschöpft weil ich
menschen bis ich getroffen habe um
gesehen habe es gibt menschen in der
kirche die verstehen und die was ändern
wollen und es geschieht was das ist es
ist unglaublich schön und ich bin
dankbar dafür
[Musik]
wieder in rom doris reisinger nimmt an
einer internationalen konferenz teil
frauen aus aller welt wollen hier auch
den missbrauch an ordensfrauen in der
katholischen kirche zum thema machen
[Musik]
aus ganz europa südamerika und asien
sind sie gekommen
der internationale austausch soll
klarmachen dass frauen weltweit
veränderungen fordern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wichtigste aber solidarität gibt
kraft
ich glaube anderer zu treffen die was
einiges erlebt haben es unglaublich
wichtig weil man erst versteht ein
anderer erzählen was einem selber
passiert ist und man versteht vor allem
ich bin nicht die einzige
[Musik]
zeit für veränderungen ist das motto der
organisation voices of fate stimmen des
glaubens die frauen haben für ihre
konferenz die prachtvolle bibliothekar
angelika gewählt um den macht bauten des
vatikans etwas entgegenzusetzen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu dieser besonderen
konferenz von äußerst fair
anlässlich des tages gegen gewalt an
frauen mit 19 ist doris in die
geistliche gemeinschaft das werk
eingetreten
herzlich willkommen doris ungefähr 30
prozent aller ordensfrauen erleben
sexuelle gewalt einige von ihnen kennen
die berichte sie sind erschreckend da
geht es um vergewaltigungen erzwungene
abtreibungen manche endeten tödlich
eine der schwestern starb bei der
abtreibung und der priester hielt auch
noch die totenmesse
was können wir also tun
ich kann meine geschichte erzählen
deswegen bin ich hier und vor allem
möchte ich dass jedes opfer das zu
sprechen wagt weiß dass es nicht alleine
ist
christus ist nicht gestorben um uns
leiden zu lassen sondern um uns zu
befreien
doris rising erlebt heute ein ganz
normales leben hat beruf und familie
aber sie fühlt sich verpflichtet andere
vor missbrauch zu schützen hat die
hoffnung dass sich die katholische
kirche ändert
wird bald weitere burke gesprochen im
besten falle kriegen andere opfer mit
dass sie nicht die einzigen sind und
trauen sich auch zu reden und der besten
falle wird der druck auf die römische
kurie zu handeln so groß dass sie es
auch wirklich tun
ich glaube dass dann wenn das nicht
kommt dass dann die kirche absolut
bedeutungslos wird und dass sie das dass
das ja das war eine andere lösung die
ich mir nicht wünschen aber ich glaube
dass ich hoffe dass es kein weiter so
geben wird warum wünschen sich dass die
kirche weiter diese bedeutung hat diese
ja ich denke die kirche ist auch eine
heimat viele leute und das soll sie auch
bleiben und dafür musste sich einfach
machen sie auch noch kirche werden die
frage möchte ich nicht beantworten diese
frage ob ich noch in der kirche bin oder
nicht mehr nervt mich unglaublich dass
wir diese klare grenzen ziehen zu können
und zu müssen das ist ja genau das
problem warum ist denn ein bischof der
über jahrzehnte kindesmissbrauch
vertuscht hat in der kirche an eines von
diesen opfern dass sich entschlossen hat
keine kirchensteuer mehr zahlen ist
nicht mehr in der kirche was für eine
komische logik ist es
im januar 2009 10 drei monate nach
dieser konferenz tritt der beichtvater
der sie in der beichte bedrängt hatte
von seinem amt in der
glaubenskongregation zurück angeblich um
diesem amt nicht zu schaden so die
presseerklärung beginnt der öffentliche
druck zu wirken
ich bin erleichtert auf der anderen
seite frage ich mich warum jetzt
ich denke diese rückte bestätigt ein
muster das wir seit jahrzehnten in der
katholischen kirche sehen wenn es um
missbrauch geht dass die kirche immer
erst dann aktiv wird und nur soweit
aktiv wird wie sie das unbedingt tun
muss bald jetzt nicht mehr anders geht
dass es kein signal für
reformbereitschaft auch italiener
zweifelt am reformwillen der kirche doch
die solidarität mit anderen engagierten
frauen lässt sie durchhalten
sie treffen sich hier um eine
protestaktion vorzubereiten
sie wollen dass man sie endlich hört
boden habe ich keine
[Gelächter]
es gibt viel kritik es gibt viel unmut
anerkennung oder ein wirkliches ernst
nehmen der kritik der vorschläge
schwierig im bistum trier werd ich im
grunde genommen übergang also seit
jahrzehnten eine der frauen erzählt uns
allerdings nur ohne kamera
es gebe auch druck der ortspfarrer habe
ihr sogar gedroht wenn sie bei der
aktion mitmachen
jetzt wollen die frauen öffentlich
forderungen stellen zusammen
volkswirtschaftlichen schaden
angerichtet hat
der stuhl ihrem essen ab und dann muss
wen sie denn noch sind die leute
begrapscht worden wo die höchsten
moralischen grundsätze erhoben worden
es wäre mir nicht in den sinn gekommen
dass da was hätte passieren können als
der erste forderung wäre den
missbrauchsskandal in der katholischen
kirche umfassend aufzuklären und die
namen der verantwortlichen für das
jahrelange vertuschen zu nennen
ich würde praktika machen wenn man dann
zur vor links da wird man die hälfte
nicht aber wir fordern zb nicht auf
skandal aufzuklären
wir fordern dann besser
die katholische frauengemeinschaft
deutschlands hatte bundesweit aufgerufen
öffentlich zu protestieren
in koblenz fanden sich aber nicht genug
teilnehmerinnen angeblich zu kurzfristig
geplant zu aktionistisch ich hab sogar
zwei taschenlampen noch jemand an der
müsst euch natürlich so steiner die
taschenlampe noch bei hinkommen nicht
alle katholischen frauen wagen es den
klerus so deutlich zu kritisieren wie
jutta lehnert sie und ihre
mitstreiterinnen wollen jetzt nicht mehr
schweigen
für das jahrelange französischen zu
nennen
wir fordern das machtgefälle und das
männer bündnisse aufzulösen
wir fordern die fähigkeit des priesters
und die parteifahnen grundstruktur zu
hindern
wir fordern opfer an der aufarbeitung zu
beteiligen
bringen
[Musik]